Carly is with us in Sacramento hey Carly
how are you tryin good Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up thank
you so much for taking my call um so me
and my husband have nineteen thousand
left in debt that we're paying off right
now and our plan is to you know after
our debt save up our three to six months
emergency fund and then start saving for
a down payment on a house that's what we
teach recently recently my husband's
been talking about that he wants to
start saving putting money aside for his
retirement now and I wanted to get some
advice on that you know I've been kind
of saying we really may stick to the
plan of just focusing on our debt right
now I don't want to see what you had to
say about that well I mean I've told
people the same exact thing for 30 years
so stick to the plan right I mean what
do you want me to say okay you guys are
broke you're in debt so your husband's
financial opinions suck okay I got look
look I got a grant Paul belly right on
the front of me if I hire a guy who's
got an 8 pack as my personal trainer and
he says Dave don't eat pizza three days
a week you're not going to ever get rid
of that belly if you eat pizza three
days a week and I say yeah but I think I
want to eat pizza three days a week he's
gonna go you wasted your time paying me
and bothering me isn't he yeah ask the
guy I asked the guy who's an expert who
has a proven track record on abs what to
do to get rid of the belly and then I
argued with his advice that's not
logical yeah I just I wasn't sure how to
how to convince him like I'm doing you
it's not logical his best opinions about
money have got you all where you are
yeah
my best opinions about abs have got a
belly on the front of me look right I
mean you got to submit yourself to a
proven system or you're not going to get
the results of the proven system now you
guys can do whatever you want to do God
knows you've been doing that for years
right yeah well yeah it's always funny
to me that people have a strong money
opinions when they're broke husbands are
you know argument is illogical it's like
it's like me calling up somebody you
know and giving them advice on trying to
grow hair on top of their head I have
none by the way and so I'm not very good
at that I'm not good at growing hair on
my head so I really shouldn't be giving
people advice on that I shouldn't take
you know you know so on so that you know
you've got to decide so you know and
he's gotta decide and as a couple you've
got to look at your life and go hey if
we keep doing what we've been doing
using our best judgment which sucks
we're gonna keep getting what we've been
getting
let's try sticking to the plan which is
what you're saying Carly and that's what
needs to happen but it's just if guys do
this more than girls - Carly guys are
the worst you know we'll stand and look
at something and still have our own
opinion and it makes no sense at all I
mean I'd do it I'd do it too but um so I
understand where he's coming from but
it's just he'll logical as crud it just
doesn't make sense